Israël fera tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour protéger ses citoyens et son
territoire à savoir faire tomber le
Hamas détruire ses infrastructures
militaires et éliminer la menace
terroriste que la bande de Gaza fait
peser sur ces
citoyens en même temps Israël déploiera
tous les efforts possibles pour protéger
ses otages ses frontières et ses
citoyens alors on parle beaucoup de la
situation humanitaire ces derniers jour
n'oublions pas que suite aux attaques
terroristes et au tir de roquetes qui
sont toujours en train de s'abattre sur
Israël des dizaines de milliers
d'Israéliens ont été déplacés de leur
maison dans les localités entourant la
bande de Gaza et dispersés dans dans
divers ais abris à travers le pays en
outre en raison des attaques continues
du hezbola sur la frontière nord et du
risque aigu d'escalade qu'elle
représente des milliers de résidents des
localités de la frontière Nord ont été
déplacés et de nombreux autres viennent
s'y ajouter chaque jour et n'oublions
pas que le tir des missiles et roquette
sur la population israélienne continue
pendant que je vous
parle comme vous le savez bien les
organisations terroristes opèent cement
et délibérément à partir de zones
peuplées de civiles et à proximité de
bâtiments et d'institutions humanitaires
qu'ell instrumentalise